why you
L and you
CH and you try to make full L of
[Applause]
[Music]
sh
so as we get into our discussion about
Generation X much like X Factor we need
to take a step back and we need to talk
about a previously existing story in
order to make sense of why it is that
Generation X came into existence now
this previously existing story is an
event called The failinks Covenant and
this was an event that was launched by
Marvel that crossed along almost all of
the X-Men related titles now at this
time Generation X wasn't necessarily A
team but the failinks Covenant gave us
an introduction to these individuals who
would later on form the Generation X
team but it would also introduce us to
existing villains and existing
superheroes and people we were already
familiar with who in turn would either
contribute to the Generation X team
formation or else lead the Generation X
team now with the failinks Covenant what
we had seen here is that if you remember
our discussion on Cameron hodj we had
talked about how he had undergone
multiple Endeavors in an attempt to
circumvent the efforts of the X-Men and
to also try to destroy mutant kind and
the failings Covenant was yet another
step in that direction with this story
what we saw was that Cameron Hodge
alongside Steven Lang a man we haven't
talked about yet but who is considered
by many to be the grandfather of the
Sentinel program had both undergone the
process of allowing themselves to be uh
I guess assimilated by the fail Lang and
again the failinks are this amalgamation
of sentience and technorganic I guess
technology that has merged into a single
conscience with a hive mind and under
the I guess so-called control of Cameron
hodj the failinks as it was confined to
the planet Earth had undergone the
process of assimilating various human
beings but the goal of Cameron hodj here
was to assimilate mutants But as time
progress with regards to the failen as
it was controlled by Cameron hodj the
eventual attempt here was to eliminate
all of humanity and to replace Humanity
with the failinks proper but what we had
seen as the story had progressed was
that Cameron Hodge Steven Lang and the
fail lanks had encountered a problem and
that problem was that they weren't able
to assimilate mutants and so as time
progressed what they decided to do is to
go after the younger generation of
mutants and by virtue of going after the
younger generation who hadn't quite been
trained in how to use their powers they
would have found very little resistance
and in capturing this younger generation
of mutants they would have been able to
experiment and to find out what it is
that would allow them to assimilate
mutants thereby going after the rest of
mutant kind now over the course of this
comic we saw several things taking place
with this story We of course saw that
Banshee was more or less the one to kick
off the whole fail Lang Covenant and
this in the event that led him to the uh
Xavier Institute whereby he started
speaking to various X-Men and found that
they were all acting a little strange
and again skipping pretty fast over the
course of the story we eventually lead
to a set of circumstances whereby uh the
fail lanks are free by various or I'm
sorry the uh the younger mutants are
freed by various superheroes in addition
to both Banshee Emma Frost as well as
Sabertooth and Jubilee and so on which
ultimately leads to the character blink
sacrificing her life in order to allow
the younger generation of mutants to
escape now blink is a very important
character in The Realm of the events
leading up to generation next and what I
would like you to pay attention to is
that with this event with the the
character blink she is going to be
someone who is for the most part going
to to disappear about a month after she
was created but Marvel's going to bring
her back with the Age of Apocalypse and
because of her popularity in the Age of
Apocalypse storyline she's in turn going
to be brought back to the main Earth 616
Universe albeit much later on after the
age of apocalypse story has come to an
end but because of the events of the
failings Covenant because of the impact
of the story as it affected the younger
generation of mutants this would
eventually lead us into a situation
whereby both uh banshee and Emma Frost
are the leader of this new generation of
mutants which are learning to develop
their
[Music]
powers so before we get too far into our
generation x Story one of the other
things we need to focus on here is the
issue that was going on between Emma
Frost and Banshee now Emma Frost and
Banshee both had their own situations
that led them to where they currently
are of course Banshee was previously a
member of the X-Men he had left the
X-Men you had Emma Frost who was trying
to reform herself from being a villain
as part of the hellfire club and trying
to establish herself as a good guy and
Generation X would be the the medium in
which she would choose to do that after
Generation X came to an end we would
actually see her rolled over into the
main X-men group which she remains a
part of today but with Generation X as
we start a Generation X issue number one
we meet up with Paige Guri and Paige
Guri is of course the sister of
Cannonball but what she has is a very
interesting ability which we'll pick up
here in a minute but as we pick up with
her character we see she's joining
Jubilee and of course again Jubilee had
been part of the X-Men for a little
while up to this point but where the
X-Men were constantly involved in uh in
Crazy situations where they were
constantly in and out and testing their
abilities and putting their abilities to
their use Jubilee was still discovering
what it was that she was capable of and
so in many ways she was lagging behind
and so what generation x allowed her to
do is take a break away from The Hectic
lifestyle of being an X-Man and focus on
learning about how to use her abilities
proper and so this is the reason why
she's part of Generation X but in
addition to this we're going to see over
the course of the series that she's
going to uh provide a few words of
wisdom here and there and use her
experiences with the X-Men to get them
out of some rather hairy situations but
between Paige and Jubilee we see a
little bit of Woody banter here the two
of them are just kind of uh giving each
other some slight jibes nothing too
major but what we see with paig Guri is
the power that she possesses Paige has
the ability to remove the skin from her
body and underneath will always be a new
form if she chooses for her it's what it
is that she wants it to be in this
instance after a long run she peels the
skin off of her body to reveal a new
coat of skin a fresh body that is not
soiled with uh any kind of sweat or or
Grime or anything as a result of her
perspiration and running and so from
here we again see that uh while she gets
a little bit of criticism from jue that
the witty banter continues but as the
two of them are talking we see that
they're joined by Mona St Croy now Mona
St Croy is a very very important
character in the realm of uh of the
Generation X stories and in fact for the
most part the entire uh I guess run of
Generation X is going to give us these
little bits and hints and reveals in
terms of what it is that's going on with
with Mona St Croy but as we'll see later
on and especially with this story we're
going to be introduced to a villain
named implant we're also going to see
later on in uh in stories with
Generation X the introduction of some
named Penance and what we need to do is
we need to keep in mind that with these
three characters with mon St Croy with
impet and with Penance that nothing is
what it appears to be that there is a
very interesting story going on with
these individuals but mon s Cy has a
multitude of powers given to her of
course because we had seen various
characters most of the characters in
fact from Generation X introduced to US
during the failing Covenant story line
we had already met up with Mona St Croy
and mon St Croy has powers that are very
similar to Miss Marvel but what she also
has is telepathy and this of course
leads her to the mindset which she
constantly reminds everyone that there
is precious little that she doesn't know
as as she would say but as the three
girls are continuing along they meet up
with Shan Cassidy with Banshee and at
this time Banshee is the mentor of uh of
Generation X and this is one important
thing I would like you guys to remember
Generation X does not exist within the
Xavier Institute that is to say they
don't exist within the same I guess the
school for gifted Young ERS instead
they're in a totally separate area they
don't learn directly from Charles Xavier
they're more or less being monitored and
being taught by the combined efforts of
both Banshee and Emma Frost and with a
little bit of uh I guess a little bit of
humor here what we see with mon say Croy
is that she asked banshee if he can
carry her bags in which of course being
a gentleman he agrees but then we see
that she actually has several truckloads
of things that are being brought in and
of course again this is just a little
bit of humor being brought to the
situation at this point we trans
transition to a man named Jonathan
starsmore and Jonathan starsmore is
going to go by the code name chamber
after a few stories within the
Generation X uh Comics now the important
thing to also remember about uh about
chamber is that during Generation X he's
relatively important he comes in he
helps his teams out from time to time
but it's not until after Generation X
comes to an end where he is uh
introduced to the clanic Caba where
apocalypse's blood is used to heal him
and he takes on an appearance that's
very similar to apocalypse
that his character becomes a major focal
point within the X-Men Universe again at
this point with regards to Generation X
with the exception of Jubilee this is
simply just a chance for younger mutants
to gain their powers to uh learn how to
use their powers proper and to decide
what road they want to travel but of
course with Jonathan Jonathan starsmore
what we see is that he's been extended
an opportunity to join the uh The xavor
Institute to join the Xavier school for
gifted youngsters to learn how to use
his abilities now for the most part
again focusing a little more here on
Jonathan one of the things I'd like you
to notice is that he seems to be this
kind of castoff this kind of uh maybe
misunderstood character and this is one
of the reasons why so many characters
within the Generation X story were so
well-received because they were a
depiction of what teenagers were like in
the real world and so a lot of teenagers
were able to look at these stories and
they saw themselves teenagers who felt
like they were relegated to the outside
who weren't part of the mainstream who
weren't welcomed into uh some of the
more popular groups could look at a
character like Jonathan starsmore and
see themselves whereas characters like
Paige characters like Jubilee or
characters like uh like Monae people who
identifi with those characters could
look at them and find some sort of
common element and so from here we
switch to a person named uh sit and uh
and sit has the ability to I guess copy
the abilities of anybody within a
certain range of him able to mimic their
powers and so if any of you guys ever
watch the TV show Heroes he's very
similar in in fact almost identical to
the abilities of Peter patrelli but what
we see with uh with this character is
that he's going about his time
presumably attempting to track somebody
down or maybe locate someone at this
current moment we're not entirely sure
but as the stories continue we meet up
with another person and this person
appears to be the individual that he's
trying to uh trying to track down
someone named Angelo and what we learn
with Angelo is that he has 6 feet of
extra skin and so he's able to
manipulate his body in such a way to
where it's very similar to Reed Richards
now where he doesn't necessarily have
the ability to stretch at such a length
as Reed Richards does he still has the
ability to extend appendages to extend
his fingers and uh bound people up to
wrap them up different things like that
but what we see is that uh both cinch
and uh and and uh Angelo were engaging
in maybe some kind of a uh a fight or
maybe some kind of a combat But as time
progress it appears that's what's what's
going on here is really more of a
training session or maybe some kind of
again a fun experience experiment
between the two of them to see who can
come out on top from here we switch back
to Monae Paige and Jubilee and as they
enter what appears to be the training
area we learned that again this place is
very different from the uh Xavier
Institute for gifted youngsters instead
of having a technologically advanced
danger room we have what Jubilee refers
to as a danger Grotto and as Sean
Cassidy explains to us this place does
not have any kind of circuitry there's
no techn technology for it to go wrong
instead it's just pristine nature and so
what this is going to do is give them a
chance to focus directly on their
abilities for as often as they can
without ever having to worry about
anything breaking down in addition we
see that of course the group is joined
by cinch and Angelo and as the two of
them are combating as the two of them
are going against each other and uh and
for the most part I guess uh fighting we
of course see that Banshee tells them to
break it up he tells them that they
don't need to be fighting each other
this needs to come to an end and he ask
them whose idea it was for the two of
them to cross train against against each
other for the two of them to uh try to
best one another at this point we're
joined with Emma Frost and Emma Frost
said that it would have been her idea
that it is her idea that the two of them
go against one another for the simple
purpose of trying to expand on their
abilities and this again is where we see
that uh for the most part Emma Frost is
more or less heading this institute
which of course again is something that
we'll touch back on when we get to Emma
Frost proper and we're focusing on
things like the Helens but again for the
most part Banshee is the mentor he's
simply just the uh the head te teacher
so to speak and Emma Frost is the one
that's actually running this separate
Institute but with these characters uh
we see that for the most part they're
going head-to-head that they're bumping
heads now we won't find out later on
until what's going on between the two of
them about what it is that's taking
place but again this is simply just the
two of them trying to decide how it is
that they should both run run this
institute together what we also see is
that Jubilee appears to notice someone
somebody very small now again this is
someone that she catches out of the
corner of her eye but we don't actually
see who it is because when she turns
around this person is gone but at this
point we again join uh the rest of the
team as they're heading about their uh
normal business apparently going to
breakfast from here we transition to the
Logan International Airport and we join
up with an unidentified man and an
unidentified driver but it appears as
though both of these individuals are
waiting on a person called Jonathan
starsmore and uh the person who is
apparently riding in the back seat where
uh I'm sorry driving the vehicle says
that he should be arriving shortly and
that apparently the purpose is to
somehow capture this person from here we
see the person in the back seat saying
that uh for the most part he doesn't
seem of any real use to anyone so what
is the purpose of him being here in the
United States that for the most part he
was cast off initially and so the
question is why is he here and again all
we're really getting here is this idea
getting this understanding that there
are uh there's for the most part an
enemy forming in the background of the
story as it's being presented to us from
here we again switch back to Jubilee and
Jubilee is uh for the most part just
continuing her conversation and talking
with various members of generation Next
Generation next and for the most part
just trying to uh find her place within
the group as each of the individuals in
this group are attempting to do but for
the most part the only person that seems
very confident here the only person that
seems to really have any uh strong
bearing of who she is in terms of her
identity is mon St Cy which again is
something that we'll touch back on later
on but as the group is joined by Banshee
Banshee asks them whether or not he
wants whether or not they want to attend
or I guess go with him as they're
traveling around and as they're doing
various things but when St Croy of
course turns them down and says that she
believes her efforts would be better
served exploring the campus but Jubilee
of course chooses to uh to join Banshee
from here we see that mon St Croy takes
uh notice of the person that jie had
seen before and again this person is
given to us in terms of a uh in terms of
maybe some description in the fact that
he may be older than time or that he's
been around for quite some time or that
he's very wise and very knowledgeable
but the name that this person has is
given to us by mon squi when she refers
to him as Gateway now admittedly I'm not
very knowledgeable about Gateway in fact
I really haven't read that much about
his character and my investigations into
Generation X was actually my first
introduction to him so for the most part
I'm about as clueless as uh as anybody
else when it comes to who he is or why
he's here but what he tells mon Croy is
that again while he's not answering her
directly his actions say that this
individual that a person has apparently
returned and for the most part this is
how we're going to see Gateway I
guess involving himself with uh
Generation X in the sense that he's not
going to be speaking directly he's
simply just going to be uh I guess using
his body language to tell them what it
is that they need to know at this point
we transition back to the Logan
International Airport again and we uh
we're back with this individual who
appears to be shrouded in some kind of
ethereal fog or or something like that
but what he's telling us is that all
these humans appear to be something that
he has a disdain for that he hates
humanity and that his name or as he's
being referred to is impet now again
impet and mon St Croy and who we'll
actually see later on a person named
Penance all have this very complicated
story about the three of them and this
is of course something that we'll expand
on later on in this video but what we
learn about impet is that he apparently
has the ability to see an aura of a
person who is a mutant and so for him
mutants stand out he's able to see the
actual energy surrounding them but the
energy that surrounds them is relative
to their youth and the power that they
possess and so what he sees is an older
man who has mutant Powers but because
he's older because his mutant Powers may
have presumably been unused for quite
some time his Aura is very very small
from here we transition back to Banshee
and of course bansi and these
individuals are with uh are at the
airport awaiting the arrival of Jonathan
starsmore telling us that they've uh
that more or less this villain implant
and uh Banshee have all more or less
come together in the same place and that
inevitably this is going to lead to some
kind of a conflict from here we
transition back to impet and this is
when impet gives us the idea of what it
is that he sees when he encounters a uh
I guess a mutant with incredible power
with unbelievable power and from here we
see that impet is looking upon Jonathan
starsmore and Jonathan starsmore is
radiating all kinds of energy and so
what appears is though the intention of
implant is to actually feed on Jonathan
Stars more to somehow maybe consume him
or to consume some energy now what we'll
learn later on with impet is that what
he actually does is he consumes the bone
marrow of uh of the people that he is
encountering he he consumes a bone
marrow of mutants that will in turn
sustain him sustain his energy levels
but again there's also a little more to
this character as well and so what we
get is this situation whereby Banshee
alongside um impet are both more or less
engaged in this rush to get to Jonathan
and stars more but impet is the first
one to reach him and impet grabs him and
when he does he begins to feed on the
energy that Jonathan starsmore is
letting loose and for the most part
again impet is simply using this to feed
himself he's using this to uh bring
himself one into this full-on Dimension
but two to uh give him the the energy
necessary to maintain his power and of
course we see that uh that Banshee
alongside Jubilee is able to jump in and
to keep uh I guess impet at Bay or at
the very least to drag his attention
away from uh from Jonathan starsmore but
as impet looks around and he notices
Banshee he of course knows who Banshee
is but what he also says is that there's
a vast amount of power that's present
here that he can see their power that he
can see what it is that makes them who
they are and again there's a little bit
of witty banter here with Jubilee saying
that she's going to kick their butt but
for the most part impet lets off a vast
amount of energy and this is one of the
powers of impet impet is able to copy
the powers for a short time of the
people in which he's consumed and to
combine those powers and so what he does
is when Banshee had initially screamed
at implant implant was able to combine
both the uh the Sonic screen of Sonic
scream of Banshee along with the powers
of Jonathan starsmore and channel it
back at the group and so from here we of
course see that uh since Jubilee and
bans you're attempting to overcome this
conflict and for the most part this
situation begins to switch the situation
begins to turn and what I mean by that
is one of the things that impet is most
familiar with is that when he feeds on
someone that for the most part they're
never usually able to fight back but
instead Jonathan starsmore begins to try
to overpower empet he begins to try to
use his ability to channel it back at
impet and to uh Force impet off of him
and for the most part impet is surprised
by this he's surprised to see that
someone's able to use his power while
he's siphoning power away from him and
so uh for the most part Jonathan
starsmore is able to blow impet away
from here we of course see that for the
most part um Jonathan starsmore
alongside Jubilee and cinch and Banshee
have in effect come together to
challenge the actions of impet and empet
says that uh again he's going to feed on
all of them that he's going to consume
all of them but before he can come too
much further we also see that paig and
Gateway and uh enkin and Mona St Croy
join up with everybody and again
bolstering their ranks in an attempt to
uh fight against impet but for the most
part what what mon St Croy says here is
that again there's precious little that
she doesn't know and this of course is
in response to the question that Paige
had asked of how was it that she knew
that everybody was going to be here that
they were in a conflict that something
was going to happen but again because
mon Cy is not being very specific here
Paige simply just takes it upon herself
to go after uh implant of course Banshee
says no he says that this isn't
something that needs to happen but Paige
goes after impet anyway and when she
does impet is able to use his claws to
swipe at her flesh and to kill her or I
guess to uh to attack her but what we
see is that Jubilee is able to save um
Paige's Life by removing the covering on
her skin that reveals another layer of
skin whereby she's totally uninjured and
this again is where we see for the most
part one of the better attributes of
PA's power that instead of her
constantly being in a situation whereby
she's on the of death that instead her
skin can be removed thereby allowing
some measure of a healing factor that
would in turn allow her to jump back
into the conflict again but what we see
is that for the most part Emma Frost
alongside Banshee and the rest of
Generation X have effectively come
together as a team this is an instance
whereby they are all fighting together
against the power of impet and impet
says that uh there will be a time
whereby he will return there will be a
time when he will come back and when he
does he is going to wreak his Vengeance
on uh Generation X at this point we
joined back to uh the Xavier Institute
for gifted youngsters and of course
Generation X as they're talking as
they're meeting with one another are
joined by Jonathan and Jonathan says
that for the most part that the
attention is needed that the attention
is needed of uh Banshee and of course he
doesn't immediately say why and for the
most part it doesn't seem as though he
knows but what Banshee does is he goes
out to the front lawn and he meets with
Gateway and Gateway says that uh for the
most part there's a person who is
arriving here there's a person who is
coming and that the person who is coming
is a person named Penance and that this
person Penance is going to effectively
change everything or at the very least
that seems to be the perception and of
course as a Story begins to come to a
close we see that Emma Frost alongside
Banshee in Gateway realized that there
is some kind of an unconscious woman
laying on the front lawn but that this
woman Bears a striking resemblance to
empet
so where Scott loell and Chris Ballo had
created Generation X what we saw was
that over the course of their run of the
Generation X Series that the story and
the series itself became incredibly
popular and the reason why is because
this was an instance whereby teenagers
were able to identify with these
superheroes with the X-Men we saw some
very cool stories we saw some very cool
situations and a lot of really gritty
human ity going into the stories but
teenagers couldn't really identify with
the X-Men because the X-Men were adults
with Generation X it wasn't that way we
saw characters like Paige and Jubilee go
through the process of what it was like
to be a teenager of learning about
themselves of learning about what they
stand for and what their ideas were but
at the same time these were all
compounded by the fact that they had
superpowers and so they were one a cast
out from the rest of humanity trying to
find a place within mutant Society but
two we also saw these situations where
they were thrust into dangerous
scenarios they were thrust into
dangerous conflicts now over the course
of the series impet remained a Mainstay
in terms of being a villain for
Generation X but what we saw was that by
issue number 34 or so that Scott loell
and uh and Chris Balo had left and in
their place we got Larry Hama and what
Larry Hama did is he introduced to us a
series a five-part series between issues
number 35 and 40 where we got the
backstory or the true story behind what
was going on with Monae St Croy now from
this point going forward what we saw was
that the Generation X stories began to
dip a lot of people didn't like this
reveal they didn't like this concept but
what Marvel did is in 2000 they had
hired Warren Ellis and they had hired
Warren Ellis because he was very very
good at taking the teenage concept of
sarcasm the teenage concept of feeling
misunderstood of feeling cast out and
enhancing it more so than Scott loell
was capable of doing and so what we saw
was that between 2000 and 2001 that the
stores became popular again that a lot
of people had jumped into the idea of
Generation X and this is where
Generation X differs from a lot of the
other comic Marvel comic titles that
have been cancelled Generation X wasn't
canceled because the stories had slumped
because the viewer base had walked away
instead it was canceled because Joe cada
wanted to uh I guess he wanted to
consolidate all of these X-Men titles
for him there were too many X books and
so what he did is he of course did
things like eliminating the Marvel
Knights imprint but what he also did is
he had uh Generation X cancelled and he
had the remaining members of Generation
X dispersed among the uh remaining X-Men
teams this is when we saw Banshee move
on and form excore this is when we saw
Emma Frost become part of the um the
main group of X-Men this is when we saw
Monae St Croy the real Mona St Croy
become part of uh Storm's all female
X-Men team this when we saw things began
to shift around and we saw everybody
move around until until we got to the
point where eventually we ran into House
of M and we of course saw for the most
part that a lot of the characters began
to go away with that being said we're
going to go ahead and bring this video
to an end I hope you guys enjoyed it if
you did let me know and I will catch you
guys later
peace what's going on guys this is Rob
and um I wanted to make this video to
talk to you guys about patreon and U and
the whole reason for this is because
some of you guys have expressed an
interest some of you guys said that you
were interested in uh in something like
patreon a couple of you guys have left
comments some of you have sent me
messages and so on